five years ago my partner on the film
Robert Gordon came across a bootleg tape
and watched it and I think we were
instantly struck with how incredibly
contemporary it was in one way which is
the issues they were talking about were
exactly the issues of today that we're
still dealing with with foreign wars and
race and gender inequality and on and on
at the same time the way they were
speaking and their percentage on
television having that much time to
speak uninterruptedly V was completely
foreign it was you know somebody says he
de the past is a foreign world you know
we don't recognize it you know it's and
there was something about that that was
completely transfixing and we we felt we
wanted to make a movie right away you
know it took us five years to make this
this was five years ago when we started
the process and we didn't know if
anybody else thought that there was a
movie in this but we intrinsically felt
that there was this great story that
said a lot of things we wanted to say
and part of that was robert and i both
started as journalists we were big
believers and the power of media to do
good and this just seemed like the
ultimate kind of cautionary tale about
about media and as a way of kind of
testing the theory that this might
become a film we sent out some interview
requests and i think the first requests
were to Christopher Hitchens Frank Rich
James Wolcott and Dick Cavett all four
of whom wrote back instantaneously
saying come come now and that was a good
sign and by the time we left that first
interview we knew we had a film and then
we just had to convince other people of
it you did a fifth you had a fifth
person you interviewed and ended up not
using any of that gore himself yeah we
interviewed wasn't good enough for your
film it's complicated so I as full
disclosure I actually used to work for
Gore not that he would remember it but I
certainly remembered it that my first
job out of college was working for a
short time as a fact checker for Gore
which was certainly the worst job of my
life because they'll Gore was brilliant
and I had incredible command of facts
and would quote passenger
from memory it was my job to tell him he
wasn't perfect and that was a very very
thankless job but in terms of doing the
interview you know we ask or to do an
interview and of course he said yes
because you don't turn down sex or
appearing on television and but I don't
think he really understood what we were
going forward so and so we go up to his
house is when he moved back after his
partner Howard had died he moved back to
Hollywood he had a house in the
Hollywood Hills and it was a scene from
Sunset Boulevard a big Spanish mansion
and we set up in the living room and he
had this kind of manservant that brought
him in and a wheelchair there's about a
year and a half before he before he died
and angora wasn't making eye contact
with us and by way of making polite
conversation something in our crew said
my grandfather served in the Aleutian
Islands when you did and he said he
couldn't get warm the entire time he was
there and gore looked up at that moment
for the first time and made eye contact
with us I must burning eye contact and
said I had my rage to keep me warm and
that was that was the beginning of a
very very long interview we did but why
was it unusable well I Gord disagree
with the premise of our film which is
that he and Buckley were in any way on
an equal plane there was no comparing
that I'm sure Buckley agreed completely
exactly that's one of the only thing the
only other thing they ever agreed upon
was they never went to see each other
again but I think gore I mean he accused
us of being Buckley i'ts it was a very
difficult strenuous interview and at
that point his life he was in chronic
pain he wasn't in great shape you know
we were talking about this just outside
so at the end of this long long
interview his servant kind of wheels him
away and takes him upstairs and comes
back into the room and says mr. Vidal
would like to know if you'd like to have
cocktails with him upstairs and of
course we're both in need of cocktails
and and just wanted to to see what you
couldn't turn down as no no no we had to
know what was going to happen so we went
upstairs and we thought we were going to
be led into a den or a salon and instead
we were led into Gore's bedroom at which
point cord was already back in bed and
gore gestures sit down boys and there
are no chairs in the room so we all sat
on Gore's bed and had cocktails and had
a lovely 90 minute conversation with him
where he was completely different and
all that being said I don't think he
ever would have given us a different
interview than the what he did then what
he did that combined with the fact that
Buckley had died in 2008 and it somehow
felt unfair to have Gore speak and not
Buckley I mean gora already kind of had
the last word as it were and it just
didn't ever feel right to put that in
there is so much archival material out
there on YouTube you happen on to this
debate in this footage what made it
contemporary enough for you what was the
click in your mind and in Roberts mind
that you said we can make a movie about
this that people want to see because of
what's happening today well I mean
really more than I mean the issues were
exciting but the thing that really got
me was just the drama of it I mean it
was just incredible theatre and here
were two guys an understood theater like
very few people ever have and
particularly as public intellectuals
ever have I'm so tempted to sit here and
knock my pencil look exactly she meaning
for the back in your chair but I mean
gorab was a playwright and am
screenwriter and understood theatre
incredibly well and how to deliver the
perfect bomoh and Buckley I really think
Buckley's first love was debate not
politics picking in many many of his
friends would say he didn't want to talk
about politics when he wasn't on
television that he wanted to talk about
history or art he kind of had a salon in
his apartment in New York with his wife
Pat who had a large circle of both gay
and liberal friends and most of
Buckley's friends were liberals I mean
he told one editor at the National
Review who told me this upon moving to
New York the Buckley advised him don't
hang out with conservatives they're
deadly boring hang out with the Liberals
I don't think the doll would have done
the opposite
in watching it I see the thread the
contemporary thread with the idea of
this incendiary discussion that isn't
really debate these men at least in what
we saw weren't so much debating in the
issues as in provoking each other into
flights of higher and higher rhetoric
although in a way again this being kind
of at the birth of identity politics in
1968 and you know Nixon southern
strategy and the the kind of commingling
of the personal and the political so in
a way gore being a homosexual or Buckley
being a strict Vatican one Catholic were
political stances I think they thought
that the personal attacks in fact were
there to further their own political
agenda and the other thing where it
diverges from modern day and I was
taking notes on it you heard subjunctive
you heard compound sentences you heard
ball to dash and heuristic and Pericles
I'm not hearing that out of James
Carville and Sarah Palin no no in fact
in fact you know there's a
anti-intellectualism in America
certainly and I find back to Stephenson
and eggheads yes Eisenhower exactly but
it's just gotten worse and worse and
television certainly plays a part in
that but now it's almost as though
people pretend to be stupid you know i
feel like you know george bush went to
Harvard and Yale but pretends he's just
a guy cutting brush Obama kind of has
this everyman accent I hear him use on
the cats when he drops the G at the end
of the word yeah it's like what you know
why are you pretending not to be the
smart person you are but that's kind of
what you have to do to get over on
television these days and when you use a
big word when I occasionally see people
use the word not like Hobgoblin ization
but you know something like that that
they would um they apologize for it they
apologize see people kind of say well I
know nobody's going to get this but you
know nobody's going to remember this bud
but they're certainly not talking about
Pericles